So, okay, so, how we, how we going to solve this?
>> Okay, so, I guess the first thing to do is if you look at the
table you have at the bottom, it tells us what the truth tables are for AND
and XOR, alright? So, we know that Boolean
functions, can all be represented as combinations of
and or N not. So, I'm going to recommend you feel out that empty column with OR.
>> So, OR is like that.
>> Right. And you'll notice, if you look at AND OR and
XOR that, OR looks just like XOR except ,at the very last row.
>> In the second, okay good, uh-huh, and in that row.
>> Right, and, AND on the other hand, tells us a one only on the
last row. So what, I'm going to suggest that we really want that last node
to do in your drawing, is to compute the or of X1 or X2.
And produce the right answer, except in the case of the last row,
which we only want to turn off when and happens to be true.
So ,really what that node is, is computing or minus and.
>> Alright, so how do we make this or minus and?
So the way we did or before Well we did it a couple of different
ways. But one is we gave weights of one on the two inputs. And then a
threshold of one. And that made, ignoring
everything else at the moment, this unit will
now turn on if either x1 or x2 are on. And otherwise it will stay off.
>> Right. So what's the worst case? The lowest value that you can
get. Is when one of those is one and one of those is zero,
which means that the, sum into those will be, in fact, one.
>> Yeah.
>> Right? So, if the AND comes out as being true, it's
going to give us some positive value. So, if we just simply have
a negative wait there, that will subtract out. Exactly in the
case ,when AND is on. It's not going to quite give us the answer we
want, but it's a good place to start to think about it.
>> Alright, so like just a negative weight, like negative one.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Alright. So does that work?
>> Not quite.
>> Alright, and why doesn't it work? Because if, well certainly when and
is off then we really are just getting the or, that's all good.
>> Yeah.
>> But if both x1 and x2 are both on, then the sum here is
going to be two minus the one that we get from the AND which is still one.
>> So,
minus one isn't enough?
>> Minus with both, maybe we can do more than that.
Maybe we can do minus two What happens if we do
minus two? Then we've got ,X1 and X2 if they're both
on, then we get a sum of one minus two plus
one or zero. Which is less than our threshold so it
will output zero. And in the other two cases, right, when
and is off than it just acts like or. So this
actually kind of does the right thing. Its actually OR minus kind of and
times two. [LAUGH]
>> Right. And there you go. And of
course there's an infinite number of solutions to this.